Martin Marty why a book on Martin Luther
first of all my book on Martin Luther
because there's a series Viking penguin
books on everybody from Crazy Horse to
Mozart to Churchill to Mao and around
the year 2000 there were many surveys of
who were the most important people and
what are the most important incidents of
the millennium before that's a silly
game but it's still a game and Martin
Luther came up in the top five and all
the surveys that showed up and often
Guttenberg and tying the two together of
course is interesting well if you have
that kind of figure and he's not in a
series he belongs in the series and they
asked me in that's why there's a book of
Martin Luther what would the world be
like if he hadn't come along I think
that there was enough reform going on in
Catholicism Spain Italy France parts of
what today is Germany that something
would have happened you can see the
break that Henry the eighth's did in
England on different grounds somebody
once asked me to summarise the Lutheran
Reformation and I said it's the revolt
of the junior faculty at Wittenberg
of all those that was the one that
caught and I think so a set of
circumstances his own spiritual power
his own rhetorical gift his own energy
and the drama of life in which for a
quarter century or everyday you could be
killed we pay special attention to that
kind of figure and whether Europe would
have broken up as much as it did Western
Europe was all Catholic except Jews and
ghettos and at the end of his time and
with a few people around him John Calvin
others you never again had European
unity I think he did advance whether he
wanted to or not the cause of human
freedom by placing so much on individual
conscience yes the Bible but reason and
conscience when he was 500 years old in
1983 there were some columnist is all
the attributed writing the Declaration
of Independence and the invention of the
Boy Scouts too apparently you see modern
things
long and say face up to that I don't
want to overstate the case but I think
that breaking up that imposed unity on
Europe giving people churchly options
and speaking up for conscience are
probably the two things that he greatly
advanced mourn in 1483 what was the
world like them there's a wonderful book
by a Dutch story in Johan Huizinga
was called a waning of the Middle Ages
the new translation is better it's
called the autumn of the Middle Ages and
the first chapter that is called a
violent tenor of life and I think that
really captures what had happened a lot
of things were falling apart everyone's
fighting everybody and the German
princes fight each other
France and the Pope are fighting each
other it just turmoil all over peasants
are beginning to rise feudal lords don't
have the power they used to have disease
a century before you've had black death
a third to half the population may have
died and you're never feeling secure
again there are many analogues to our
own time if is somewhere in the high
middle ages you could seal here's the
Pope here's the Emperor here the
cathedrals here the systems that isn't
working anymore unrest all over and
Luther himself is part of that the town
he goes up in they're thoroughly
convinced that up in the mountains there
which is in poltergeist for him it was
usually a devil as many as roof tiles he
said when he went to be tried by the
Emperor so I think the shortness of life
the threat to life the failure for the
old systems to speak to you as they had
and what many historians have found now
is studying that century in 1483
typically is that under the official
symbols the Divine Trinity the mass all
the official Catholic and Christian
symbols people as one somebody said they
smuggled in their gods and plain brown
wrappers but they made pilgrimages they
made a great deal of relics superstition
we would call today
and the Catholic historians looking back
on that would say that now to everyone
was in power was less secure and acted
frantically because they were less
secure than they had and a system of
Thomas Aquinas and the official Catholic
philosophy is being challenged at the
new universities so unrest unrest unrest
insecurity and security and security how
many people in the world well we don't
know about the larger world we know that
I know the population Wittenberg but big
was that less than 2,000 people and that
was where that is in what is called
today in Saxony it was in East Germany
and it's still not much of a town it
existed only because the local prince
wanted his own University and that was a
place where he could plant it but it was
a nothing place I can't give the
population things I don't know if
everybody knows the estimates we can
kind of guess how many people have been
Antwerp and Amsterdam and so on but we
wouldn't know how to add it up the other
map you have in your book is the
includes a look at the Holy Roman Empire
what was it then that's one of the
hardest things to get across to people
because I think they think if it's Roman
it must be in Rome and if it's holy it
must be holy and if it's an empire must
be an empire and it was none of the
three as many historians pointed out
most of its territory is what is in
today's Central Europe and mainly
Germany but Emperor's often also came
from Spain and the wandering Luther's
life Charles the fifth was from Spain
but it's basically an enlarged Germany
the lowlands the Netherlands and so on
and it was what was left of the old
Roman Empire in Italy as the map shows
you now have separate entities the
Vatican itself has its own army and is a
separate territory what we call Germany
wasn't invented till 1870 what was the
german-speaking lands then over 300
territories mutually contradictory in
rivalry they could only unite over
common enemies and the Pope became one
of them along the way it was effectual
in many ways but as the map pan which
shows those England there's France
there's the Ottomans the Turks are
coming from another direction
southern Italy so it isn't old Rome
anymore
it's a residue and it's called holy
because it was always a part of the Pope
was in on disciplining the Emperor's it
was part of the Catholic regime in that
sense though also often in rivalry with
the Vatican or the Pope what was an
emperor the emperor was someone endowed
by the Pope with special powers who
always debates about should he be
crowned all the way down in the 19th
century when Napoleon grabbed the counts
and the Pope and put on his head because
he went to be Emperor so that was very
important that he was different he had
nominal power and symbolic power over
all these separate princes but again
they weren't always content with that
kind of power he had the powers to
condemn when Luther stands before him
and he can ask closer to recant and if
Luther doesn't take him bring about a
death penalty and symbolic power
connecting power but never independent
power in the breaking up of the Middle
Ages what was a king back then
well King was what we all would know
with hundred aides and Frances first
France that is you're beginning to get
out of the mess of provinces of France a
single unity and in England I used to
always be puzzled why England had so
many wars on French soil and vice-versa
and why English Kings show up and French
soil in a strange way from the Kings
angle the English Channel was more like
a river consciously transecting accosted
but they gained power and I think the
key to their power is similar to that of
the Emperor in that's what we tried to
get rid of in 1776 the concept of the
Divine Right of Kings that is of all the
rulers all the royalty this is the one
that passes on so his genes and through
his anointment
or in was of this case for transmission
they had a special power and you weren't
supposed to question that power of
course you did but you weren't supposed
to how many years did you teach at the
University of Chicago I taught exactly
35 years I was on a committee that was
supposed to solve the problem of what to
do when they could no longer fire you
when you were of age and eight of us
said we will quit at the minute they
would have made us quit we could go on
forever now so I quit at 5:00 p.m. March
20th 1998 and I began at midnight July
1st 1963 thirty five happy years what
you teach all over the place Chicago has
very low boundaries between disciplines
I was in three faculties divinity
basically paid my salary the Divinity
School at Chicago is not a separate
seminary it's like Law School Business
School etc it's older than the
university I taught in the history
history department which there is social
sciences and I taught in humanities and
also taught other graduates for most of
the years I was originally to have
taught what we called Atlantic culture
northwest Europe North America then I
became an associate dean for a few years
and couldn't get back to sources in
Europe and I had a large family and
mother stay put so I became an American
is peer and simple until late 80s my
last 10 years I was drawn into a whole
new field American Academy of Arts and
Sciences asked me to had a project to
study comparative militant
fundamentalisms around the world and we
got 200 scholars busy and five fat
volumes grew out of it and then we began
to study comparatively the way religion
is involved in ethnic disputes
Yugoslavia in Human Rights South Africa
and so on so I became an implicit
internationalist but my route and my
love has been American on the other hand
my whole life I am a Lutheran and all my
life
Luther is off there somewhere so when
they asked me to write a book on him I
was ready to go
why are you elusive I was born with her
next one thing I have a
I thought about it now we're born in
India I thought it would be a Hindu
being trained to be a university
professor you are also trained as you
train others to question yourself and
everything and so I've had a lot of
occasion to question I'm basically happy
there I like the core of what it's about
but like all human institutions it's not
just a movement it has the same flaws as
everywhere else I am and have been all
my career 50 years deeply involved in
the ecumenical venture mmm was Atlantic
and two things like that and so the last
dozen years on interface things but for
me part of the childhood training partly
that every time I tested it I came close
enough to what it was about that I
stayed with it partly its family and the
culture around it and the culture around
is a big part for me being Luther means
being with you want to buy Sternbach
being with more music than anything else
the grand musical tradition and I guess
I would say if I'm being a little
skeptic some day and asking questions of
its words I'll go into a church on a
Saturday afternoon when organisms
practicing and hearing him do these
grand Corral's and that probably
ministers more to my faith in Who I am
which is I think to probably most
traditions a lot of Catholics aren't
real happy with the dogma but they like
aspects of the ritual or the ethos or
whatever so that's I had plenty chances
to flee the coop and I chose not to you
say that out of 6 billion people in the
world 64 million of MARTA Lutheran's yes
where are they mostly located well they
were mostly located in Europe including
Eastern Europe but the collapse of
Eastern Europe also meant the collapse
of most of us resume was in one of the
main centers of the resistance to the
regime and the quiet revolution that
helped topple the Berlin Wall these are
people marching with candles out of the
church in Leipzig Tomas here who were
Bacchus to play and where Lutheranism
was preached but
once they like that enemy Soviet enemy
East German government was a sagging
because for all those years
47 years 50 years 75 years in a sense
from blini until the end and you have
oppression of religion and there was
just enough allowed that the oppression
didn't give you a power the Soviet
oppression was so much that everybody
Baptist at the Jehovah's Witness and
Orthodox and so on hung together the
data curtain fell everything was shown
well like most of Europe Scandinavia was
the Lutheran homeland and in Scandinavia
there's a tremendous decline so some of
the 64 million Lutheran's are probably
just on the rolls from that and North
America has about six and a half or
seven million but the growth is in
Africa you can't keep up with the growth
in Africa I once spoke at a seminary
called Luther seminaries the largest of
the Lutheran seminaries which was a
transplant of Norwegian Lutheran's and a
lot of people in that tradition looked
back I was on the board of st. Olaf
College there which is that too
most people aren't Norwegian there but
you look back to that route and at their
banquet I spoke and the president of
Seminary was just back from Namibia
before we were allowed to call it
Namibia by the US government and he said
you know you think Lutheranism is in
Norway more Lutheran's worshiped in
Namibia last Sunday than in Norway and
that was this little symbol Tanzania and
many such nations and that's what a new
vitality is Martin Luther King why would
a father named his son Martin Luther
King I was asked recently I knew Kings
somewhat he wrote for a magazine of
which I was one of the editors and we're
not intimate but really be together
often now and then somebody said did you
ever compare your name's why are you
named Martin and how he got Martin
Luther King and son economy no I never
asked that I know that it was named
Michael
originally but the name was changed and
if you think of a struggle in the
african-american churches they love the
symbols of breaking free Martin Luther
King often identified with the prophets
so with Moses you're always seeing
across the Jordan to a promised land and
so figures like that were important to
them and my hunch is that the dad-e King
that revenues are Baptist looks ahead
and looks at this boy and looks at his
future and thinks this is a good name he
calls me all kinds of trouble because
while doing research on this any time I
would try to access Martin Luther and
find out you get tens of millions of
Martin Luther King's to clutter it and
as somebody had told me that in our part
of the world the three people about whom
most rioting had been done were Lincoln
and Napoleon and Luther and I want to
certify that well I could get Napoleon I
could get Lincoln but they're too many
Martin Luther King's for me to do that
freedom freedom freedom I think that's
what's behind the choice of that name
Martin Luther lived for how many years
1483 to 1546 which makes him I'm not
real good at math such a success or yeah
the light of the years fourteen eighty
three to fifteen thirty are the years
the biographers all like there was a
film about him last year and it ends in
1530 that's when the movement gets put
together in his last 16 years I have a
friend Mark Edwards at Harvard who has
written a book called Luther's last
battles he said all you other people get
exciting dramatic young Luther and I
guess our Oh Luther and sour Oh Luther
kept doing some very important and good
things I think his commentaries on
Genesis that came out of those years are
really rich worth reading I make that
one of my basic text in her in fact but
the Reformation didn't go the way he
wanted her to he really was sour on
Wittenberg he didn't like to go back to
it
he thought that Germany would have a
moral reform that it didn't have he
thought that everybody would come
flocking to his catechism and he had has
a BLEVE the police I guess you say
enforce that so he's a very disappointed
person frustrated that the Jews didn't
BIRT he thought they're all going to
could work when when you get he read the
Hebrew Scriptures as the Christian Bible
and so when Jesus comes along that's
just fulfilling that so why wouldn't the
Jews all come running and well it must
be the rabbi's who are calling them so
he spewed out terribly anti-semitic
things and the Empire is breaking up and
you're facing the issue of the Turk the
Muslim he called him Mohammed --an
somebody said they the Turk is Luther's
luck he wouldn't've been alive the word
for the threat of the Turk along the way
he read the Quran had paraphrase but he
at least knew what was there and
sometimes he sounded friendlier to the
Turk than he did to the Pope in his last
years to the Pope had become for him the
Antichrist and the language that people
then used is the whole volume of
exchange between Luther and Thomas More
when we think of as a cool humanist the
man for all seasons the language they
use is good we couldn't use in this
program or anywhere else that's just how
it was and that shows up mainly in his
late years
what were his mother and father like the
mother came from the family that
probably had been landed but there
wasn't any land left
she wasn't impoverished I would say they
were a lower middle class in their
ancestry but his father looked like the
Bragg he came from peasant stock but his
father was a speculator in an owner of a
copper mine which was a very dangerous
business you could get killed you could
lose your investment and so on and I
think that contributed to a lot of the
things in his life and his father wanted
Social Security and insurance which
meant his son had to earn some money and
that meant should be a lawyer and he was
outraged when Luther chose not to be a
lawyer to become a monk Erik Erikson the
great psychoanalyst wrote a book called
young man Luther in which he took some
clues out of Luther's relation his
father and tried to make it seem as if
Luther was nothing but an edible figure
and or that his mother was very severe
because Luther was she once wrapped my
knuckles Kalle bled the more I read it
the more I don't
and that explains his life what young
person doesn't have some kind of
attention as to what the family dream is
in what you turn out to be and in the
late years when his father was dying he
wrote very tender letters to him which I
don't think you do they're not repentant
letters you know sorry that I did this
to you dad but rather I'm close to you I
will meet you in heaven we'll finish the
projects put on now
I think the father moved into
upper-middle class in one sense in that
the town they moved to had five citizens
who represented the grievances in the
interests of the town folk to the prince
and to the magistrates and Luther his
father was elected to that so he wasn't
a poor peasant did he ever marry
he married interesting story if you read
the 19th century Catholic histories they
always sort of made a theme as if the
guy so brimming with lust he had a care
of the church apart so he could get
married
well if so it took him seven years to do
it and he was kind of dragged screaming
into it seven years from what from while
of departing from the vows of celibacy
and myiasis ISM was he by his own action
he would have been free to marry seven
years earlier than he did by the way do
just on that point was he ever a priest
yes people don't need Catholic fruit yes
he came in as a monk and very dramatic
story he's supposed to be a lawyer and
having visited home he's on the way back
to the University Airport there's a
lightning bolt strikes him down and he
has already told us he said even the
trembling of a leaked leaf can make me
tremble so he's obsessed with his guilt
his smallness his meaninglessness and
that lightning bolt comes and he says
st. Anne and saved me and I will become
a monk Saint Anne was the patroness of
miners by the way so his father prayed
to Saint Anne and he became a monk and
while in the monastery a man I call the
best talent scout around and my favorite
Catholic of the century Johannes punched
which became his mentor listen to his
confessions spotted his talent and
pushed him on into getting a doctorate
and get anymore date and the ordination
meant then that he could say Mass and
for him to hold the bread in the wine
which were now very literally the body
and the blood of Christ and he's an
unworthy person he had such trauma it
almost didn't go through with it
he took the police took very seriously
when asked is it very seriously but when
the change came some of the people
around him started marrying if you no
longer invest celibacy with the same
aura of authority that you once did then
why not marry and he began to write a
great deal on that his key thing was
that the lay person every baptized
person is on the level you might be
called to be a priest or a pastor or a
monk he wasn't against monks if they
didn't have to take a vow what they did
was find they studied they prayed he
liked that and all that could work but
he wanted to be so sure that everyone
was equal and that could be part of your
first question what was another part of
his revolution one line the publisher
and editor suggested I not keep because
it was confusing was this the Luther
says when a little child is baptized he
comes sputtering up from the water and
is already a priest a bishop and the
Pope I want to say on page two and so at
7 years old little Pope Martin and went
off to school they said that could be
confusing but it gives me a chance to
make the point of that leveling and all
right now you are ordained as a priest
and he thought he kept all the powers
that came with that not that you're
above the others but that God has called
you to say mass into counsel and to
preach and then you take away celibacy
and then you value marriage and he began
to write a great deal about that I did a
book once called Protestantism my least
exciting title and the English publisher
added a colorful woodcut on the cover
that everybody said they got it upside
down but it was was a Reformation era
woodcut of a church standing on a
steeple and you look closely you see
that the monk is pushing the plow and
the layperson is saying the prayers he's
turning it all over and he calls the
vocation your call to that and now
marriage is a vocation and he makes a
great deal of that but he didn't follow
through in a hurry one night they
smuggled some nuns out of a convent
again these were often very young girls
large families you can't support them
and you put them in a convent and
they're there for life well a lot of
them chaste and if this mission convent
they were taping and the guy who
delivers herring there puts them in
barrels and smuggles them out and Luther
and his friends job to marry them off
there's no economy for a single woman
and one of his left over Catherine from
Bora who also came from a family that
had been landed but didn't have land
anymore and he lined her up with
somebody that she didn't like and she
said you're the one I had what had they
did and I say here that it wasn't a
romantic marriage but it turned out to
be affectionate how old was he
well well into his 30s I can't think of
the exact date of the letters in my
notes say 42 42 okay how old would she
have been was she younger the TV younger
him and she outlived him and I think
what's interesting in their development
here some modern feminists say well he
didn't finish the job you want an
education for girls he wanted women to
marry which is a great feminist thing to
think of but it's still a low ceiling
there's nothing else their place it was
Catherine's and Borah who must have been
a very talented and be very
strong-willed maybe even sharp tongue
she ran the place and they they were
given a wing of the old monastery and
whether people are training for ministry
and it was like dorm living frat house
living and she's cooking frogs Hebrews
the beer for them she raises the pigs
she cards the wool but most symbolic to
me is at the end he has her right there
will and run the estate and this is
really unknown
for a commoner to be handling the state
so she's a very strong person I made
children five or six while one of them
died very young magdalena and i like to
stress that it was a again he's he's on
the road a good deal it wasn't around
all the time but there's a clear bond of
affection we have letters that he wrote
between him his son hunts and him
but when magdalena died I think 14 years
old or so he said of all the times I've
had doubt about temptation I've wondered
if there's God if there's anything to it
this is the one time I really broke with
God
I lost my face I fell in his out I think
that's a symbol of how attached he he
did become to them and overall a warm
family life that went on and on their
people in America today who are direct
descendants of of the Luther kids and it
wasn't skull family what's the
difference between a monk and a priest
well the monk among can be a priest
increased to be a monk but the monks who
are brothers can't say Mass they don't
have all the duties they're the actual
priestly role in Roman Catholicism of
standing in in the Apostles dead right
straight down from Peter the hand of the
previous generation of bishops on your
Bishop and your Bishop on you makes you
and alter Christus another Christ in the
presence there and so when you are
saying the words this is my body this is
my blood and the prayer that to over
simplify turns the water and the wine
into blood and the bread into the body
and that you're producing Christ and
that's the huge concentration of what is
to be a priest them and the monk the
normal monk who is not ordained to be a
police candidate and what years did he
serve in the cluster in the month well
it's my burning stir in the early 1520
so he would have been 17 plus 20 he's
well into his mid-30s and his transition
out of it is kind of casual first of all
he's released
from his vows by his superior stop it's
to give him more freedom again stop it's
really saw what he had on his hands here
and to release him from those vowels
meant he's less likely to be killed
because if you are in the vows and
you're a heretic you're much more
vulnerable than if you're a layperson
out there so he's released from the vows
early on and and he kept writing things
the only thing he really complained
about monasticism was that it was about
and he thought that the problem with a
vow was you took the vow in order that
that would make you get closer to God
that you were ascending that you were
achieving something so they could pray
they could study they could do good
works they did charitable works that's
all fine but you can't use it to earn
salvation how much if he came back today
there are six billion people in the
world a million I'm sorry a billion
Catholics and a billion Protestant how
much those billion Protestants would
exist if Martin Luther hadn't come along
Oh a large percentage I think
vying with the Lutheran's in size around
the world would be the Anglicans the
Episcopalians and I think that they
would have existed apart from him now in
the first generation a great number of
their leaders went to Wittenberg and the
other German universities there was a
lot of intellectual interaction there
but the Reformation had started ready in
England other Wickliffe and Tyndale a
century earlier so I think that would be
present what form it takes I don't know
the Anglicans always wanted to stay
closest to Rome but Rome always rebuffed
them because they weren't accepting
papal authority what about the rest in
America the strongest influence was
indirectly from Switzerland John Calvin
and up into England into our Puritan
tradition and so the Lutheran's have
never been a strong center of what's
going on in America whether Baptists
come what about just come in in his own
time there were people on the continent
that were called Anabaptist they were
the ones who said Luther you're too
conservative you're keeping
the mass communion with a different set
of meanings but you're keeping it and
you're keeping infant baptism for Luther
that was the most important thing to say
about faith I was baptized born February
5th baptized February 26th and as far as
the Lutheran theology is concerned
that's the most important day of my life
because that's when you become a part of
the recipient of grace in a special way
and your faith goes out and a good
Lutheran every morning makes the sign of
the Cross and says a prayer to remember
your baptism that you get a new start
don't worry about yes tomorrow no gild
about yesterday a new start it's really
huge the Anabaptist said that's a magic
the Catholics are doing what about this
whole business of infant baptism faith
has to be something that you are
conscious of and that you're doing it
isn't only a gift it makes perfect sense
to make at the strong feature and they
were Anabaptists they were in
switzerland they were in germany they
were in the netherlands they really
bugged Luther and Calvin the others and
frankly the Protestants persecuted them
as much as the Catholics did and ended
some of them were drowned by it some
were burned by it it was really a long
time they are the people who are today
in the United States are called
Mennonite Church the Brethren the Amish
are splinters of that American Baptist
and the Baptist of the surgeon around
the world they are of a different sort
and that's pretty much there's a little
bit in England mainly born in New
England for people ask the same kind of
thing how are you sure that that dirt
and creature is giving you salvation it
has to be your ascent and pretty soon
they start baptizing they moved from New
England Brown University was one of
their songs down into Virginia when the
mountains opened they went to the West
and that's why the South is so Baptist
and they spread around the world a very
strong missionary force back in the
early 1500 when he was active Martin
Luther was an imposter and all how
powerful was the Pope and who was it who
was Pope well the Pope in the main part
of his break career was a man named leo
xiii who once said that god has given us
the papacy let us enjoy it when we tour
Rome and we see the Sistine Chapel
Pope Sixtus Pope Julius they were
Renaissance princes and most of them
were quite corrupt read any history of
the papacy by a Roman Catholic and they
admitted they were fathering
illegitimate children they were often
theologically untrained one prince got
this Empire one got this one and one got
this there were some holy people among
them but by and large that had
compromised it so that on one level the
Pope officially had all the power
the Vicar of Christ all the authority on
earth got it from where got it from the
Pope before him handed it down said
you're the Pope no like today Cardinals
would vote for it
but believe that was a direct act of the
Holy Spirit that they were they would
never make a mistake before the the
Pope's of Luther's time there had been a
split of the papacy one time there were
three popes the current Avignon France
the papacy so the people she had grown
rather frail but now it's getting back
its power and it has its army and it's
fighting over defending the territory
and wealth and that's why we have
Sistine Chapel and they have the
beginnings of st. Peter's in Rome but
they didn't have enough wealth and the
Pope needed money from the other side of
the Alps and there as we see the limits
of the Pope's power the people there are
starting to say the difference between
his spiritual power the authority he has
to say who the bishop will be and what I
can go to Mass and be baptized in his
temporal power which they're rebelling
against I have a picture of a heaven
ease of a church pew beautifully carved
in Germany in the 14 70s I think of the
gates of hell
flames the devil and the people are
pushing the bulb into it there was there
was tremendous popular resistance to the
Pope which weakened him a good deal and
then when you have various practices
they didn't like all of which the
northern princes thought was going as
Luther's prince said we need our own
churches why should we pay for the one
we'll never see so the Pope has
tremendous spiritual power but he had to
fight for his place along the way and
Leo the tensest didn't catch on to
Luther early on he is the one who
excommunicated him he's called in a wild
boar
running through the vineyard of God
metaphor he probably got because he was
a wild boar hunter he'd spent a lot of
time wild boar hunting so he could apply
the metaphor to Luther what year did he
excommunicated exactly of
excommunication again my I should get my
math in I don't have to guess what it
was obviously before he was married oh
yes yeah so it had to be they would be
it would be about 15 2015 17 is the
beginning of the break when he posts the
theses so are those the next 2-3 years
are the times when all this is happening
one of the reasons I'm fuzzy on the date
here is it's a several step process
first you get the warning and then the
actual date of the the burning he we
make so much of the burning of the
people bula the bull the document that
says you're out
but maybe the more important thing you
did with that same morning was burn
canon law canon law was the name for all
the church law and this was his way of
saying that doesn't apply Church should
not be ruled by law he makes the point
the church is ruled by the gospel the
base the faith state is ruled by law and
by burning that and then having his own
excommunication go with it and from then
on he said he's a hunted person by by
emperor anybody a layperson could could
kill him with impunity because he's
condemned that condemnation comes in 15
20 at the diet of worms when he stands
before the emperor and says that famous
line that he couldn't step back unless
convinced by reason and scripture and
from then on in it could happen but it
didn't happen because he had the
protection of the Princess Mary and the
German princes diet of warms is what
diet is a kind of a an ad hoc Parliament
slightly called the Japanese diet yes
yeah and so it's an imperial thing the
emperor has to be there for it happened
to have an imperial diet and Luther is
getting so uppity and the things are
spreading so fast and the German princes
aren't controlling and the Emperor steps
in and it's City Cathedral City of warms
one of the great city had been a Jewish
stronghold in the Middle Ages
quite a beautiful famous city
the right setting for the Emperor to be
there and a whole show now is say go you
have your last chance to come back it's
almost humorous how in his earliest
years Luther thought what he was doing
would appeal to the Pope and his
archbishop he sends the 95 theses almost
a fawning language you know my beloved
Prince to the church you'll be really
happy that we're getting rid of all
these corrupt practices he bet wrong
there you mentioned that the Pope's were
corrupt but you say that the Pope's for
vicars of Christ why would the average
person then follow a pope if they were
corrupt what I mean the why would Christ
establish a church that allowed pulps to
become corrupt
that's the question Luther asked and
that was what part of the Reformation
was on the one hand I think I have to
say always Christians believe that God
can work through brokenness somebody
once asked me you're a Lutheran and you
write history and where's your
Lutheranism show and I said Luther once
said God carves the rotten wood God
rides the lame horse and that's a big
part of the Christian understand you
want nobility you want sacrifice you
want humility you want honesty but you
don't always get that perfectly and I
think that the Christian people have
been trained that no matter what the act
technical word is XO Pareto Pareto going
through the Act however corrupt the
person is doing it was doing it the act
is God's way of acting upon you and so
you know your army might fight against
the Pope and still the Pope could
excommunicate you you'd have no power
there were times the Middle Ages when
the Pope would excommunicate an emperor
and the Emperor that meant and then
pronounced an interdict which meant no
priest in your territory could say Mass
well that's a pretty scary thing because
what if I die I'll go to hell without it
the Pope had all those kinds of powers
along the way so in a certain sense the
average person didn't really have the
means to question or to act upon the
question
the intellectuals are starting to ask
the questions and it's breaking apart
but I think the common people are just
sable he's our Pope and God ordained him
and and we'll live with it how much does
that have to do with the Pope
controlling all the avenues
communications the printing presses the
you know the ability to learn new things
what was taught in your schools
I mean it was it a case where they were
brainwashed no here's the place where
the Pope had least power what is
happening is the rise of universities in
bologna and paris and oxford and so on
and they're all obviously all catholic
everything loaded in every Philosopher's
Catholic but they are really thinking of
new ideas William of Occam notably come
up with a whole new philosophy which is
called the new new theology or
nominalism and they start putting more
authority on the Bible than on tradition
etc and so he had read that real trouble
actually controlling the director of the
university would control and he'd be
responsible in a pope but a lot could go
on and the Mystics Martin Luther's first
two publications were books of mysticism
well mystics can never be reined in it's
like in our own time the mystic is not
might be Catholic mystic but you're also
off on your own somewhere and so and and
most of all the first part of what you
asked about the printing press he didn't
have control here is where Luther and
the Lutheran's really got the jump on
him and they they'd been publishing ever
after Gutenberg but they didn't quite
catch on and some people say that
Luther's genius at knowing how to use
this medium and the Entrepreneurship of
Wittenberg and Strasburg was the center
of putting Luther never made a penny off
his writings which come to 110 Polly
hosted German did he make money at all
was he was he a rich family done no no
no he was the window when the friendly
Prince gave a couple of
goblets to him and his wife at marriage
she had to hide them because she was
afraid he'd hock them and sell love it
was that kind of thing and no he always
had to worry
once you don't have the support of a
monastery once you don't have the
support of the papal system you're an
evangelical they call them they didn't
call him Luther evangelical pastor where
are you going to get the money for it so
he's always out there trying to raise
funds you say that the Catholic Church
sold indulgences
what are indulgences and how much do
they saw him for okay a sliding scale is
how they sold them and the belief was
present and it's still this amount a
little bit Pope John Paul the second
disappointed a lot of us and a lot of
Catholics by you know premium on them a
few years ago it's still on the books
but not widely used the sense that after
this life if I'm on the way to heaven
I'm carrying such a burden of sins of my
fault in this earth that I cannot have
made them up no matter how pious how
generous I was but the Saints had done
so much that they had a surplus and
that's put in kind of a treasury of
merit and how do you get access to it
you get access to it through indulgences
which were piece of paper that's
certified that you had done this
transaction
now in one sense you could have done
this through repentance so penance but
needing money for st. Peter's Church in
Rome and that kind of thing they
patented a system in which mainly one
man became known Johannes Tetzel a
Dominican monk who would go from town to
town and he'd have a little piece of
paper which he'd sell it was a sliding
scale if you're a poor peasant you get
everything out of you could whereas if
you're rich they could do a good deal
more and the more you did of this the
more your time in purgatory would be
shortened and this was to Luther and the
common people the heart of it all
actually the beta of a piece of paper
far as Luther's concerned everybody's
running off Luther's prints wouldn't
allow Tetzel in his territory Luther's
princess at his own system he had 17,000
relics that people would come to see a
thumb of the saint or something and
they'd make his money off that and the
indulgence is competed there so
let me ask you about all this one of the
words that you use in your book a lot
and Luther years a lot was faith we'll
go back to the Pope so you say the
publisher corrupt and they sold things
like indulgences what why wouldn't it
lead somebody to say that popes gathered
around their cardinals and they said
let's establish a church let's say to
everybody you got to have faith you
can't prove to you what it is but you've
got to have faith and then they say
we're going to raise money by selling
them ways to use their faith to buy
relics to buy indulgences to get
themselves into something called heaven
and this is all not true even me what
would if you're a Lutheran what
guarantee do you have that faith matters
it it really existed there really is
something beyond okay first of all with
the Pope Luther never said that there
had not been faith or there had not been
a church as long as you have the Lord's
Supper the reading of the Bible
baptism there's always the church it may
be corrupt or anything but it's the
church they're God's Saints they were
never ruled out as late as just as late
as the year of Luther's death his
sidekick still could say if the Pope
would be reformed we could have a pope
that is motherís somebody has to rule
isn't it what problem was that as far as
they were concerned faith had been so
compromised by the system of merit and
work you had to achieve it so much that
faith meant nothing so for the Lutheran
and for Luther it all turned around he
started reading the letters of Paul and
some of the hebrew scriptures that talk
this way that your whole relationship to
God is based on God's initiative God's
action God reaching down and God doing
it all now you can resist you can deny
but faith is the grasp upon the gifts of
God
now where's the security of it and well
faith is faith you don't you don't have
security like you thought you had with a
piece of paper called indulgences and
that's what bothered with it and prints
they're going off and buying their way
into it and that has to be done away
with that's why he did the 95 theses
which said the whole Christian life
should be repentance
repentance means 180-degree turn the
course you're on you turn all the way
around so that God can act upon you and
everything that was got based on on on
the grace of God the downward action and
the Facebook that you receive it let me
read from your book because you also get
into the the downside of Martin Luther
he wasn't as true to his beliefs
sometimes the most traumatic case in
point was that a philip of HESA yes an
important leader in the smile cultic of
smell college league and one who
advanced Luther's cause he was a
womanizer who had been tied through an
early arranged marriage to Christina the
daughter of Luther's political Archduke
George of Saxony Philip complained that
Christina was surly and given to
drunkenness and she stank
he must have overcome the offensive odor
enough to get close and sired ten
children she bore three of them after he
had taken a second wife without
divorcing Christina you go on to talk
more about you know the whole idea of I
don't know use word annulment but they
did Martin Luther looked the other way
well yeah he couldn't figure a way out
of this
he needed a prince and the prince needed
him so he asked what's the least worst
thing well he didn't believe in divorce
so the Bible urgent Luther didn't that
would have been easy if he just said to
Philip offense you can have a divorce
but he thought the Bible had absolute
prohibition against divorce unless there
was if if dopes wife had been unfaithful
divorce would have been a solution but
she was she was faithful so there was no
way you could have a divorce polygamy
was brought up and that was a Lutheran
quite know what to make of it because
the great patriarchs were all polygamous
and there's no page of the Bible which
says you can't be polygamous but it was
against the law it wasn't Melissa this
wouldn't be other times so he asked
what's the least worst would be bigamy
but since it was against the law he
shouldn't own up to it and if he's asked
he should lie here's where you see the
course of a person who starts out with
what looks like morality gets mixed with
politics gets mixed with compromise and
turns it to gross immorality is not a
defensible act in fact his best friend
Philip Melanchthon
who went along with a certain stage got
so much guilt over it that he became
psychosomatically ill almost mad and
near death over the guilt of this and
Luther engaged in some acts of healing
that helped him out of it
it's not anything that anyone writing a
biography of Luther could say you go and
do that likewise there was a sentence I
wanted you to explain it's on the same
page we're talking about that all this a
counselor
he explained sometimes had to offer
ambiguous advice that went against the
norm in order to protect an arm in this
case that of marriage without divorce
which is basically what you've been
talking about here is I read this I keep
saying well this seems like people had
it both ways all the time whenever they
didn't like what was going on they just
change the rules but you have to really
really really be up against something
there are a couple of technical terms
for this Kierkegaard talks about Abraham
is supposed to kill his own son and he
called the teleological suspension of
the ethical that is with a certain end
in view you might have to suspend
something colleague at Chicago paul
ricoeur talked about the ethics of
distress for example in in in world war
ii and one of the great novels world war
ii there's a lifeboat with 15 people
from your own ship on it and there's a
German sub underneath and if you don't
drop a depth charge
they might get your hospital ship and
kill a thousand people
you drop a depth charge you're going to
kill fifteen your own people and the man
commander drops the depth charge and
says one must do what one must do and
then say one's prayers I think that it's
that kind of thing you don't likely do
this and that's why I bring in a book to
show a grievousness of that flaw but in
Luther's theology you don't you don't
get away with that you take things very
very seriously but I think many a
pastoral counselor in Catholicism and
Protestantism in which you will say this
isn't quite going by the books but
you're a frail human being I see a
potentially new for doing something else
this is what but all wrong in the
Catholic priests the abuse things
says he was a good priest you could do
other things so we'll kind of wink at
that so the stuff can really go wrong
but I don't think anybody can go through
a whole pastor and go home every night
and say I counselled absolute virtue
every day you try to get the best out of
people and the best out of the grace of
God and that you return to the principle
right away so looks like I'd go back and
say we never gave over the principle of
the integrity of marriage he paid an
awful high price for keeping it I know
that there's a great gap between the
1300s and when Hitler came in but you
read the attitude of Martlet toward the
Jews and you say boy that goes way
that's right what his attitude was moved
all the way through the years up to the
1930s there was a book in world war two
Luther's Hitler spiritual ancestor and
William L Shire who wrote the very
famous book on the rise of Nazis made it
a popular theme and a lot of people ever
since have been wrestling with it
Schieffer ism doesn't really hold up
today anymore
but there's enough to it that the
Lutheran churches I mean the
evangelicals and Church in America
formally goes on record with abject
total surrender and reparation all kind
of thing
what should which is why and also like I
say I'm bound never to defend what he
did but it did not point out what the
differences are
Hitler's is a racial anti-semitism as
the act of being born Jewish means you
are loathsome you don't belong in human
race I have a right to kill you
Luther's was a religious one any Jew who
converted was just fine with him because
they were totally equal it wasn't your
race at all it was your denial of the
faith and the reason he struck out at
them so much was he thought that they're
going to say AHA this getting rid of the
Pope getting rid of all that and just
God's grace is what the book of I say is
about that's what a lot of the prophets
are about this is for us and of course
almost nobody converted and he was
frustrated and enraged and most of his
attacks are on the rabbis because he
thought they were the ones that were
preventing the normal Jews from getting
a
the cellar stove is is strong in tracks
at 1543 you right Luther kept
elaborating on the theme that rabbis
were calling the Virgin Mary a [ __ ] and
Jesus a bastard sometimes that I'm going
to read and turn and enrage Luther felt
license to use degrading imagery that
rabbis made Jews kiss gobble down guzzle
and worship the Shi T they were teaching
along with the Judah's P P is s of their
biblical interpretations where's all
that language come from out of a maybe
diseased mind by then your mind yeah I
mean everything in his body is not
working anymore by then if I say that
though that lets him off the hook
because he's still on the hook he is in
a culture of explaining he isn't a
culture in which that's that's the
language used that's the background used
my other hero of that century Erasmus on
my wall I always had Luther an Erasmus
your Asmus I envy you French because you
don't have any Jews and what's that all
about
Oh fifteen centuries of Jewish
anti-semitism so what's what's the basis
that they didn't convert some of it was
and that was a debate in the United
States and respect to a movie should he
have the line in there that the Jews
said his blood be on us and on our
children and that colored an awful lot
you can almost deal with those fifteen
centuries and not find a bright spot in
Christians relations to Jews they're
always seen as the villains again often
there could be a converted Jew and that
was alright but in general theologically
the Jews were at fault they were flawed
and I have a big fat book on the Jew and
Christian Ark in Wittenberg where Luther
was there's a picture of a sow suckling
and that's the biggest offensive the
Jews the sow is suckling the Jews in the
great cathedrals of Europe you always
have two figures we had often two
figures church synagogue churches
beautiful woman synagogue is blindfolded
she doesn't see the truth or you can't
read you can't write a happy chapter
there and he's a part of it modern
anti-semitism is
purely racial they didn't care about
what Jews believed and a lot of Jews had
adapted to German life we're going to be
out of time for I ask you a couple of
questions much about you
what what part of the world you grow up
in I was born in Nebraska I'm a son of
the plains I left at age 21 but one part
of my heart stays there and I like to
measure from that but for the last 50
years that ministry called and where did
you go to college or so I went to the
Lutheran College it was called a
preparatory school prep school like a
Catholic minor seminary and to to
Lutheran seminaries and then I went into
my life work of teaching and I got my
PhD at the University of Chicago and
your parents did what my father was a
schoolteacher my mother was a humble
homemaker who brought us up well and we
had a I always say I'll never write a
memoir because it can't be dramatic
because I have nothing to fight about my
early years it was depression it was
doubt it was Dust Bowl nobody had a lot
but we were nurtured well and they're
prepared for I think the my whole life
has been in a world that you'd call
secular and pluralistic I've never
LOB's ten years I was a pastor of a
flock but all my years at University of
Chicago interfaith inter religious
secular I've always been interested in
the political dimensions of religion so
it's never been cozy and I think they
prepared me for that Martin Marty has
been our guest in the book looks like
this it's a penguin lives series and
there is Martin Luther on the cover he
was out all night all he was he was
skinny when young and fat when old and
and and people said he would see every
bone in his body so when you cast him as
a young person he's that way at the end
he said I'm ready to die now and give
the maggots a fat doctor to eat we're
out of time this is what the cover looks
like thank you very much for joining us